الى شرق اسيا ونقطه توتر اخرى متجدده هناك
حيث وصف وزير الخارجيه الهندي سوبرا
مينيام جيشانكار وصف الوضع على الحدود بين
بلاده والصين في منطقه لاداخ غربي جبال
الهملايا بانه هش وخطير واضاف الوزير
الهندي ان قوات البلدين تنتشر بالقرب من
بعضها البعض في المنطقه الحدوديه وقال ان
العلاقات الهنديه الصينيه لا يمكن ان تعود
الى طبيعتها حتى يتم حل الخلاف الحدودي
وفقا للاتفاق الموقع في سبتمبر عام 2020
الذي توصل اليه مع نظيره الصيني واندلعت
اعمال العنف القطاع الشرقي من الحدود غير
المرسمه بين البلدين في ديسمبر الماضي ولم
تسفر عن ضحايا يذكر ان 24 جنديا قتلوا في
اشتباكات بين الجانبين منتصف عام 2020 قبل
ان تنجح محادثات دبل وماسيه وعسكريه في
تهدئه الاوضاع